[Music]
[Applause]
certified broadcast meteorologist jim
cantori the weather channel jim where
are you today
uh dan it's so funny i mean you actually
gave away the city right there nobody
took the bait nobody grabbed onto it um
i'm right there in the heart of boston
yep right on the long walk that's what i
thought
now what do you bring on a trip like
this and how long do you pack for
well the bags are already packed um but
two pairs of boots three pairs of gloves
different hats
um
you know some protein powder just just
crank you know everything to get me
through the storm
all right now do you know
the definition of a blizzard
i do there's three things
three things the last time you asked me
a meteorological question i failed
yesterday i will not fail you yes you
asked me what a southwester was and i
was like what the hell is that it just
skipped me but the blizzard you got to
have um 35 mile per hour plus wins
that's one three hours or more right and
a quarter mile visibility of snow
or less during that three hours
did i do all right man yeah
yeah am i still certified yeah
but what bothers you the most when you
watch
weather forecasters like local
forecasters what bothers jim cantori
um
you know what there's so many good ones
out there it's hard to say that uh you
know especially here in the boston
market this is a tough market so
i don't know it bothers me i mean maybe
maybe um
i'm not sure that i don't have as good
of hair as they do how about that you
know so eric fisher is a boston
meteorologist he probably has the most
perfect hair of any meteorologist i've
ever seen yeah but
his arms aren't as big as yours no not
no that's a good point
good point but i i was wondering about
that that you do this and then i was
like did you ever think of calling
yourself
like a gym
tornado i promise you i never have okay
because there's dallas rains there's
storm fields
right never thought about having a
weather related name
no i i never really uh did this for ego
i actually wanted to just be a
a lowly operational meteorologist so i
never really got into that whole schtick
thing
what do people say go back and revisit
that after 35 years i think what do
people say when they see you in town
um leave
[Laughter]
no they should leave they should leave
not you no they want me to leave because
they think for some reason
no it doesn't work like that explain
this to me though the local news anchor
will always thank the weather forecaster
for good weather you guys didn't do
anything
i know isn't that beautiful they'd be
like oh so uh you know jimmy lipper
great weather thank you for that
forecast but most importantly they
always blame you for when you get the
forecast wrong
shouldn't there be something you heard
that story you heard that story but from
indianapolis right
when
this meteorologist was calling uh for
six inches of snow
and so it never happened in indianapolis
it never never came out never came to
fruition the forecast and the next
morning the the anchors turned to them
both of them female
and they said to him
you know john you promised me six inches
last night
and you could just imagine everything
that ensued after that
that's what happens when you bust a
forecast bro
[Laughter]
shouldn't there be stakes though when
you get your forecast wrong
like
somebody should be fired or suspended
and that's a little harsh a little
electric electric shock therapy
i'm looking at that you could get
42 inches in providence
portsmouth new hampshire portland maine
does that sound about right
uh that would be on the high end of the
extreme for this storm um okay a 40 inch
total would be pretty pretty incredible
but
you know i think getting in the into the
20 to 30 plus ranges
is gonna be pretty pretty hard there's a
lot of internal dynamics that go along
with the storm in other words where
these what are these bands set up that
produce three to five inches there's
really no way of perfectly forecasting
that but we do think it's gonna be
somewhere in eastern maine eastern
massachusetts eastern rhode island uh
and that's where you know that's where
the money spot is and that's why i'm
here dan
that's why i'm here in boston he's jim
cantori he's been doing this for over 35
years at the weather channel paulie has
some weather related names and jim's a
brand he might not want to change his
name but uh we're thinking it's psyclone
for a weatherman name
or this one this is our favorite
humidity
hubert humidity
there you go that's a that's a little
that's a little light uh but uh i like
cyclone better i think that's special
i'll take it uh worst weather that
you've ever been in
snow wise where were you actually
nervous
i mean you know hurricanes are are
interesting because especially when the
water comes up and you've got a whole
crew with you and you want to make sure
that they don't you don't flood trucks
and flood
you know them out in the storm surge but
you know katrina was just nuts dude i
mean you're talking about 28 feet of
storm surge in gulfport mississippi
cars floating around the parking lots
like rubber duckies
huge whole trees
just being blown across the parking lot
i mean that was pretty
pretty gnarly but i mean we were in we
were we were above
dry ground you know
there wasn't much of that left can
police tell you to get out
uh they can
they can they usually usually don't um
they like to think that we know what
we're doing
and we kind of do
sometimes we don't seton is going from
uh connecticut
to los angeles
and he's leaving on monday
gotcha so we start february seton's on
the road
uh he's going to go cincinnati seton
give jim cantori the route so hold on
when is he leaving first of all from
connecticut monday morning
so you're so you're doing that because
of the storm
no we we're getting the van delivered
yeah we're not worried about safety this
is about getting the van delivered that
they're going cross country yeah
jim thinking it's about that so that's
why you called on me for this sport yes
yes uh monday you're fine wait a minute
hold on seaton give jim the uh the tour
stops okay so yeah we start monday we
leave connecticut to get to cincinnati
then uh from there we go to memphis
oklahoma city phoenix hold on all right
hold on let's let's do day by day
because
that's that's kind of the way i want to
talk about it five-day forecast
right right so so milford is since
you're good on monday uh sensitive
memphis you should be good on tuesday as
well there's the next weather system
starts to come into play
uh
probably wednesday there
and this is what i think is gonna be
interesting for you is you're gonna go
from memphis to oak city right well
little rock little rock is also in there
too oh is little rock where's little
rock
it's memphis then
yeah and then oklahoma city
all right uh
on wednesday
well i don't know
that's that's the plan yeah yeah we're
going to try it for wednesday so here's
the deal that could be an interesting
situation you got rained possibly
freezing rain by time you get to
oklahoma city
see that's why we avoided we didn't go
through st louis actually because i
thought there was going to be weather it
looked like there might be some weather
there yeah the farther north you go the
worse
you may have to come down to dallas
then you got albuquerque after oklahoma
city
okay
i got oklahoma city to phoenix
so dan you need to talk to your
producers i need some information right
no they're okay so i gave jim has the
like the end destinations there's
there's stops in between so we're going
to drive through nashville but probably
stay in memphis you know what i mean
that's it those
rock oklahoma city albuquerque phoenix
exactly las vegas and then l.a yeah so
let's just say you're in oklahoma city
on wednesday all right and you're
leaving to go
to albuquerque and then phoenix
um
i mean depending on how much ice they
get there now and if you're in oklahoma
city that's obviously going to be a
potential hamper for you on thursday
right that's thursday's travel right um
and then i'm wondering why
why would you go from phoenix up to
vegas
why wouldn't you that's it's not a
direct line to los angeles uh what's up
with that if you're rolling through you
might as well
you got you got something you got to do
and take care of in las vegas yeah i
mean it's none of my business or
anything but
he's got to drop off somebody's money
okay um you'll be you'll be fine uh
you'll be fine whatever whatever you got
to take care of there yeah um and then
vegas to la on saturday
i think you're looking good so the big
one is freezing rain in oklahoma city
that's it when wednesday is interesting
and then leaving thursday uh depending
on how much they get there is i think
makes it tricky
um so what if we leave sunday we can
avoid all of this we can't we have to do
it monday
damn just throwing this out no i
appreciate that suggestion
can't
leave monday yeah drive into the ice you
know what if you can i don't know if you
can but if you think about this maybe
early next week if you're on the air
um as i said you know on the dan patrick
show or seaton o'connor is uh traveling
through nashville or memphis or oklahoma
city with freezing rain
i
i mean i i know you got work to do but
you did do push-ups on the air when i
asked you to do i tell you what if you
tell me why seton's going from phoenix
uh phoenix to vegas
i'll say it on the air next week how's
that satan do you want to tell ken tory
why don't you open that up
that box
man that is dicey yeah you know what i
that happens in vegas thing you know
yeah
well you want to text it to me but
you're not in vegas
so it's not what happens in vegas you're
outside of vegas you can talk about that
i think i'm just doing uh sort of some
reconnaissance for pr perhaps a future
visit to vegas is what i'll say honestly
yes yes it's such a great way you don't
want jim having to give shout outs to
brandy and cinnamon on the weather
channel
mercedes all right we'll just cross that
one off
yeah very good
mercedes to the main stage mercedes to
the main stage uh
so you're going to be in downtown boston
for tonight but tomorrow is when the
festivities start
yeah literally
right out of the gate tomorrow morning
and they start talking about these
snowfall rates
you know three to five inches an hour
which is just insane
i like to call that like the puking
phase of the atmosphere
i mean because it's it's you can't keep
up with it you shouldn't be out in it
you're gonna get trapped on the roads
and that kind of snowfall rate do you
love thunder snow
oh do i ever yeah do i you know what
though i was just it's funny before we
came out i was just talking to my
producer steve pedrak i'm like pederack
i think
i think we're gonna miss the
thunderstorm here it looks like it's
gonna be boston
uh southeastward so we may just miss it
maybe the cape gets it have you ever
been hit by lightning
i haven't yet
but
i should be careful about loving thunder
snow since lightning precedes the
thunder as you know dan
in your limited meteorological training
you know this
you call yourself a meteorologist you
haven't even been struck by lightning
yeah
uh you know i'm sure storm fields or
dallas reigns probably got hit by
lightning did dallas retire i think so i
think i think i think he did there i
don't know if there was a better looking
weather man than dallas reigns
well
dallas had great hair too oh my god he
always looks like he stopped
he stopped into the studio before you
know then he was going to a piano bar or
something like he always he always
looked like he was in route to a country
club so no in dallas he probably did the
weather forecast from the piano bar yeah
probably could have i know
uh it's great to talk to you be safe
yep and uh and and we'll be in touch
that sounds good dan anytime you need me
thank you but um give me some more
details on that phoenix videos
jim kennedy
he is certified certified broadcast
meteorologist he's not one of those guys
that you say uh we need a weather guy
i'll do it
i don't know 35 plus years at the
weather channel